[Music]
within the vastness of the universe
humanity is not that big of a deal
we're not here because we're meant to be
here
we're just here
if mathematical predictions are correct
we might only have 760 years left
what would be the cause of our
Extinction
what would we do if we knew exactly when
our existence would come to an end
and could we delay the inevitable
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we knew the exact time when
Humanity goes extinct
1993.
in 1993 knowing that Humanity's time on
the planet is limited astrophysicist J
Richard Gott made a very daring
prediction using nothing but statistics
[Music]
basically he calculated that there's a
50 percent chance that the end of human
life will come sometime before the year
2779
that gives us 760 years to make our
final arrangements and possibly pass the
Earth on to a new life form or even
leave the planet to itself altogether
stick around and we'll take you on a
journey to the future of humanity
on April 13 2029 the near-earth asteroid
named epofus will pass within 31 000
kilometers of our planet
that's 10 times closer to Earth than the
moon is
and even closer than some satellites in
orbit
but this 370 meter wide asteroid won't
hit the Earth
instead it will sweep by safely and
continue its path around the Sun
reproductive technology would allow
parents to preview and pick the genetic
traits of their future babies
the global population would grow to
about eight and a half billion and reach
a crisis point
the world's ecosystems would change
faster than we've ever seen before due
to increased levels of CO2
up in the Earth's orbit everything from
spent rocket stages to debris from
accidental collisions would create a
wall of space junk
it would be problematic for any
spacecraft to leave the Earth
we'd have to find ways to clean up the
upper atmosphere if we didn't want to be
trapped on Earth forever
if Humanity managed to solve the space
junk problem we'd start establishing the
first lunar bases
and that would Mark the beginning of the
permanent human presence outside of
Earth
on Earth the global average temperature
would rise by one and a half degrees
surpassing the safe limit
even though Humanity completely switched
to clean energy sources
global warming would become catastrophic
and hard to control
due to warmer global temperatures the
Great Barrier Reef would lose up to 90
percent of its corals
the Amazon rainforest would largely be
destroyed by wildfires and deforestation
even after Decades of conservation
efforts at least one million species in
the wild would begin to go extinct
[Music]
this would be the beginning of the next
mass extinction event in the Earth's
history
although this time it would be caused by
humans
the Earth's population would grow to 10
billion people
the Earth would become the hottest it's
been in the past three million years
extreme weather would Rampage around the
world
Africa the Middle East and Southeast
Asia would be most affected by floods
hurricanes and droughts
parts of the planet would become
uninhabitable leaving 140 million people
no other choice but to seek Refuge
someplace else
[Music]
biotechnology implants would become
available to the general public
resulting in humans merging with their
technology on a biological level
never failing artificial organs
synthetic blood and nanoscale brain
interfaces would become a new reality
sea levels would rise upwards of 6
meters forcing hundreds of millions of
people to leave their homes
large-scale evacuations and resettlement
programs would be needed along the
coastlines costing Humanity trillions of
dollars in the process
because of the declining fertility rate
and the significant number of casualties
from environmental conditions Earth's
population would stabilize at 11 billion
people
by the 2180s humanity would start
expanding into the solar system
mining asteroids and terraforming Mars
would be underway
more people would have access to space
technology and a new form of terrorism
would emerge
it would be possible to hijack a
spacecraft and use it to redirect
asteroids towards the Earth the moon and
Mars
the lack of space infrastructure would
leave space colonies particularly
vulnerable
[Music]
spaceships powered by anti-matter
propulsion would take Humanity outside
the solar system
automated unmanned probes would be sent
to the far regions of the Galaxy
researching thousands of interstellar
worlds
by the end of the 23rd Century humans
would have confirmation of a microbial
alien life existing on a warm wet
exoplanet within 100 light years of our
solar system
Decades of nanotechnology research and
advancement would result in transforming
the general public into transhumans or
cyborgs
transhumans would have improved
intelligence and strength
among many superhero traits they would
be able to Sprint at very high speeds
become invisible or even transform their
appearances at will
Humanity would level up from a type zero
to a type 1 civilization on the
kardashov scale
that means humans would be able to
harvest all of the Earth's energy and
use it to power up their entire
civilization
they would already be able to control
the weather and global climate
alter the course of earthquakes and
build cities at the bottom of the ocean
The Next Step would be developing ways
to fully manipulate the sun's energy
they might start building space
megastructures like a Dyson Sphere
or even attempt to feed some of the
Sun's mass into a black hole
the chain of the previous events could
lead to humanity completely disappearing
from the earth one way or another
we might end up moving to space colonies
we had established
or it may not even be us anymore but a
new biotechnologically engineered
species
of course this is a rough timeline
guesstimated by futurists based on
statistics and mathematical models
if you're upset about Humanity's coming
Extinction remember that it only has a
50 chance of coming true
scientists calculated our date of
Extinction using the same formula that
marketers use to predict what product
you might click on online or who you're
going to vote for
it's about probabilities not guarantees
[Music]
besides other predictions tell us that
we would face Extinction not 760 but 10
000 years from now
in that case we'd be around long enough
to see the Earth's poles reverse around
the year 3 500. and computers reaching
their ultimate potential sometime after
the year four thousand
but how would knowing all this in
advance change the way we live our lives
well if we knew the date of our
Extinction with 100 accuracy we could
stop caring about our environment and
our bodies
we might focus on all the bad habits
that only bring us short-term happiness
our society could become more violent
more self-harming more inclined to start
wars
or we could team up and try to get off
this rock
we could start looking for other places
to move to beyond what our own solar
system has to offer
we could establish colonies with stable
human populations
then even in the event of Earth getting
wiped out by some cosmic power humans
would continue to exist
they could carry on until the universe
itself collapsed and stopped existing
but that's a story for another what if
this is a planetary emergency evacuation
please remain calm and board your space
shuttles
you know each EO Humanity might not have
to leave the Earth in your lifetime
we should start preparing early on
not only could it take centuries to set
up the relocation program
it would take generations to move to a
potential new home
that right there is Proxima Centauri b
or just Proxima B
it's the closest potentially habitable
planet out there
its temperatures are in the bearable
range and it could have just the right
breathable atmosphere
only have to get there
how long would our journey last
how many people would we send to
populate the new world successfully
and what if it turned out that Proxima B
wasn't as habitable as we thought
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we relocated Humanity to
Proxima B
when astronomers started finding planets
outside our solar system or exoplanets
we realized that there are many worlds
out there
that meant that Earth doesn't have to be
our home forever
and that we don't have to die with our
planet when the sun engulfs in some five
billion years from now
[Music]
that we've found over 4 100 exoplanets
we've learned something rather
disappointing
not all exoplanets are good for humans
to live on
most of the worlds we've encountered are
either ice giants like Neptune or gas
giants like Jupiter and Saturn
only 161 of those planets are
terrestrial like Earth
and when it comes to sustaining human
life
being terrestrial isn't quite enough
Proxima B is very promising it orbits a
red dwarf star called Proxima Centauri
in a system with three stars in it
Proxima Centauri is small
it only has between seven and a half and
fifty percent of our Sun's mass
that's a good thing because the Red
Dwarf Proxima Centauri is so much
smaller than our yellow dwarf Sun
it burns at a lower temperature
it takes stars like Proxima Centauri
much longer to burn through all of their
hydrogen Supply
because of that Proxima Centauri has a
lifetime of trillions of years while our
sun has a 10 billion year expiration
term
that alone makes Proxima b a good
candidate for relocation
that and the fact that its orbit lies in
Proxima centauri's habitable zone
that means there's the potential for
liquid water and comfortable surface
temperatures
if we're lucky Proxima B would have an
atmosphere that we could breathe
if it does the surface temperatures
would be in the range of 30 degrees I
don't know about you but I'd move there
right now
I just need to warn you that there are a
few problems
a trip to Proxima B would be long and
very dangerous
Proxima B might be the closest habitable
exoplanet we've got but that doesn't
mean it's close
the red dwarf star Proxima Centauri is
about 4.3 light years away
that means that if you could travel at
the speed of light it would take you 4.3
years to get there
nothing we've built so far can reach
that kind of speed
realistically a trip to Proxima Centauri
in a space shuttle would take 165
000 years
give or take
that's right some of the colonists would
be born in transit
some of them would never see the Earth
some of them would never see Proxima B
they'd just live their lives aboard the
spaceship and die in space
how many humans would we need to send on
a mission exactly
[Music]
well according to some calculations 98
people would be just enough
their descendants would arrive at
Proxima B with enough genetic diversity
to populate the entire planet and that's
accounting for possible cases of
infertility inbreeding and sudden deaths
in those calculations the crew would be
traveling on something faster than a
space shuttle
their mission to Proxima B would only
take 6 300 years
but don't be surprised technology is
constantly improving
right now a scientific and technological
program called breakthrough initiatives
is looking at how we can get in the
neighborhood of Proxima Centauri within
one generation
their project starshot is working on an
ultralight unmanned probe that would
reach the star system in just 20 years
now I definitely need to sign up
but again Proxima B is really far away
it's so far that we can't even see if it
has an atmosphere
it might just happen that we would
arrive at a frozen planet with surface
temperatures of minus 40 degrees
and even if it has an atmosphere it
might not be the right one
we might still enjoy warm temperatures
but we'd be doing that in spacesuits
with oxygen tanks
or Proxima B could be tidally locked to
Proxima Centauri meaning that one of the
planet's sides would always face its
star and the other side would be plunged
Into Darkness
space flight itself could bring some
unpleasant surprises
spending an entire lifetime in a zero
gravity environment would lead the crew
members to lose muscle and bone density
they'd be constantly exposed to space
radiation their microbiomes immune
systems and Physiology would all be
different from ours
they wouldn't be the same kind of humans
as we are
they would change their values and
culture they might forget all the
farming techniques we'd teach them to
sustain themselves in space and on their
new planet
they might change their mind about the
mission altogether and just turn their
spaceship in a different direction
who knows they might even come back to
earth and take revenge for all those
years they were forced to spend in space
if that happens I'll be asking for a
refund
sending anyone on a mission like this is
a huge risk
we'd need to design and build a vehicle
choose the space Travelers very
carefully
Supply them with all the food and water
and make sure they could become
self-sustaining
we'd have to design new propulsion
navigation hibernation and life support
systems
and we have no way of knowing if Proxima
B is actually habitable well now I don't
really feel like going there do you
maybe a better idea would be to build a
mega structure somewhere closer to the
solar system
but that's a story
for another what if
[Music]
if time travel is possible
why haven't we met a single time
traveler yet
and if we did meet one how would we know
they weren't Faking It
what would their time machine look like
and how would it operate
[Music]
would there be a set of rules for time
travelers to follow and what would
happen if they decided to break them
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you met a time traveler
in 1998 a gentleman by the name of John
Titor arrived from the future or so he
said
in his timeline as he claimed General
Electric had managed to invent time
travel in the year 2034.
he even showed and described his time
traveling device in great detail
and then Titor vanished as abruptly as
he appeared
did he finish his mission
or was he real at all
how could we know
if we were able to prove that someone
has traveled from a different time it
would be very cool for science
although it might overwrite Albert
Einstein's theory of relativity
Einstein approached time as a fourth
dimension
space is a three-dimensional spectrum
that provides us with length width and
height
time offers Direction together they form
a space-time Continuum and it can be
affected by gravity
according to Einstein's theory of
relativity gravity is a curve in
space-time and technically because space
and time are one gravity could Bend time
as well as space
but you'd need something really really
big to notice any changes in the
movement of time
if you somehow managed to get yourself
close to a black hole like Sagittarius A
you'd be experiencing time at half speed
compared to people on earth
this is because Sagittarius A packs a
mass of 4 Million Suns into an
indefinitely dense point
creating a very strong gravitational
field around it
another way to travel in time is to move
really fast
the closer you get to the speed of light
the slower time passes for you if you
were a passenger on a train that somehow
could travel at 99 of the speed of light
for every year you spent on the train
223 years would have passed back at the
station
that would make you a time traveler into
the future
but what about traveling back in time
just like John Titor said he did
Titor claimed that this little machine
is what made time travel possible in any
direction
the c204 as he called it allowed him to
manipulate gravity with the help of two
micro singularities that were packed
inside
it also had gravity sensors to lock the
machine and time traveler in a fixed
place and space
Titor had this machine installed in a
car pretty much like the good old time
traveling DeLorean did
but it would only take him as far as 60
years from his time
how would you know that Titor was
actually traveling in time and not just
making it up
proving that someone really is a time
traveler might be even harder than time
travel itself
[Music]
Time Travelers could make predictions
about the future
show their futuristic technology
or even undergo some genetic testing to
support their story
maybe the best way to prove time travel
is real would be to take you with them
on their next adventure
of course there are easier ways to prove
the possibility of time travel
in 2009 the world famous theoretical
physicist Stephen Hawking threw a party
not just any party but one to which only
future time travelers were invited
Hawking didn't send off invitations
until after the party he believed that
if travelers from the future arrived
before the invitation was released that
would prove that time travel will become
possible one day he sat there waiting
for hours but nobody showed up
that doesn't mean time travel is
impossible there is a chance that time
travelers from the future will learn to
use wormholes or bridges in space-time
we haven't seen one of those yet but the
theory of general relativity predicts
that they exist
the biggest problem with wormholes is
that they're microscopic and collapsed
too quickly for a human traveler to go
through
but maybe the reason nobody attended
Hawking's party is that time traveling
might not be that precise
maybe the guests from the future did
arrive but they were too late for the
party
or maybe going back in time is strictly
prohibited for Time Travelers because if
they do they might change their timeline
completely
perhaps they're just trying to avoid the
risk of spreading any diseases from the
far future onto US
or maybe the information about time
traveling is so highly classified that
only a few people would be trusted with
it
maybe traveling back into time isn't
possible after all
maybe time can only move forward and
never backwards
maybe John Titor was one big lie
we have a few more years until 2034 to
find out
in a way we already have time travelers
In Our Lifetime astronauts on the
International Space Station are moving
at eight kilometers per second
this makes them age slower although the
difference is measured in hundredths of
a second
but if you're listening you're invited
to a reception for Time Travelers hosted
by Stephen Hawking
the party will take place at the
University of Cambridge United Kingdom
on June 28th 2009
no RSVP required
and hey if you have a chance to jump in
a spaceship and enjoy the time traveling
effects of a black hole do it
just make sure not to fall into that
gravitational monster but that's a story
for another what if
foreign
if you could take in all of human
history in the blink of an eye
well from the first steps out of the
Slime to the first steps on the moon
that's exactly where we are in Cosmic
terms but in that short amount of time
we've done quite a bit
what would you see if you traveled one
billion years into the past
did Earth ever look like a giant slush
ball
how far back would you have to go to see
the first humans
and are we already going extinct
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you went 1 billion years into
the past
in a sense we're all time travelers
we travel into the future at the rate of
one second per second
but if you want to go backward in time
you'll need to go faster than the speed
of light that's according to Einstein or
maybe your time machine would jump
through wormholes
a hypothetical tunnel that connects two
different points in space-time
however you decide to travel through the
jumbled mess of time you'll see the
effects and then the causes of the most
powerful forces that shaped our world
you might leave wondering how many times
did the earth freeze
as you watch History unfold or refold or
whatever
you might be surprised at the toll
humanity is taken on this planet in such
a short amount of time
if you start in 2021 and move backward
you would watch the sixth mass
extinction event happening right now
known as the Holocene Extinction we are
currently living through one of the most
destructive periods of our time caused
by human activity
as humans destroy coral reefs and
rainforests the numerous wildlife and
plants that depend on these ecosystems
die with them according to the
international Union for the conservation
of nature
67 of endangered species could be
extinct in 100 years and since most of
these extinctions are undocumented we
won't even know about what we've lost
until it's gone
maybe not even then
visit the 18th and 19th centuries and
you could watch the pollution created by
the Industrial Revolution reversed back
into the smokestacks
cities would shrink down and return to
their Roots as rural farmlands
while this would let you see the
explosion of the human race in terms of
population and pollution if you want to
retrace our first steps you'll need to
go back farther
tour the planet two hundred thousand
years ago and you would witness the
arrival of our species the homo sapiens
jump back seven million years to
Northern Chad and the oldest known
species of humans could stroll right by
you
known as the silanthropus chadensis
this mysterious Link in our chain looked
ape-like but was the first to walk
upright he seems friendly enough
but travel to 60 million years ago and
you'll see the first primates emerge
from the humid rainforests of Asia
okay step back to 65 million years ago
and you'd find yourself under the giant
asteroid that created a global
Extinction event
impact caused a tsunami and filled the
air with dust and debris
the crash also set off massive volcanic
eruptions across the world
with the sun blacked out and the land
flooding the last of the dinosaurs died
out
but without this event mammals like us
may never have taken over the planet
go back 130 million years and you'll see
the first flowers bloom
as you travel 200 million years back in
time you'll witness the breakup of
Pangea the mass of land that will become
the continents
as the land breaks apart the lava
eruptions will be so massive they kill
almost 80 percent of the species on
Earth
okay keep going back another 20 million
years and watch the first early mammals
small and nocturnal crawl around in the
dark and if you go back to 230 million
years ago you could watch the early
dinosaurs walk for the first time on two
legs
before that can happen though the Earth
has to go through what would be known as
the great dying also called the Permian
Extinction
95 of all species on Earth died but you
could also watch the earth's land masses
come together to form Pangea now you
could take a walk from Argentina to
China but things get interesting around
375 million years ago
you would watch marine animals walking
onto land for the first time
maybe you would see a tiktaalik which
looks like a salamander mixed with a
fish
this strange creature would later evolve
into mammals and amphibians
but just like every species you saw
before this growth doesn't happen
without a cost
and now we're at the first Extinction
event
the or division Extinction occurs when
ice sheets spread from the polar caps
into the oceans
almost 70 percent of all sea life died
off during this planet-wide freeze over
460 million years ago
okay keep going back and you could see
how life started underwater
called the Cambrian explosion the
lineage of most of the species on our
planet today can be traced back to this
milestone
but scientists are still unsure how this
unique event happened
between 635 and 850 million years ago
the earth froze over twice
once for almost 60 million years and the
next time for 15 million years one
Theory suggests that the Earth was only
covered in a thin film of ice
allowing the sun's Rays to seep through
and plant the seeds of Life Below
but go back one billion years in history
and you'll be surprised to find well not
a lot
during this time red algae are forming
spores to reproduce cells are coming
together to form larger organisms life
on Earth is microscopic and not very
threatening
but nothing has been more vicious to our
planet in such a short amount of time as
humans
but maybe humans will set things right
eventually there could be a change in
our planet or our hearts that might set
our future on a different path
or maybe like the dinosaurs and
Neanderthals
we would just be replaced by something
else
so let's take our time machine and find
out
what if you traveled one billion years
into the future
well that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
if you traveled ten thousand years into
the future
what would planet Earth look like
would most of its surface be covered in
volcanoes
or would it be frozen in ice
what if you traveled even further to 1
million years in the future
would all of the oceans have evaporated
or would it have become one giant water
world
okay now what about 1 billion years
would there be any humans left
or would they have settled in other
parts of the Galaxy
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you traveled one billion years
into the future
let's face it the chances of any humans
being around to greet you when you
arrive 1 billion years into the future
are pretty low
several key existential threats face the
human race and if we want to be around
in one billion years we'll need to
endure them all
we've seen how much we've struggled to
come together just to survive a global
pandemic
so how do we have any chance of enduring
the threats of climate change
overpopulation Global nuclear war killer
asteroids and comets Natural Ice Ages
and the sun getting a whole lot hotter
well let's take a look into the future
and find out
just under 10 000 years from now we're
going to run into a big problem called
the DECA millennium bug in the year 10
000 A.D software encoding the ad
calendar year won't encode dates with
more than four decimals remember Y2K
yeah it's just like that except
hopefully we won't Panic as much this
time around
on the bright side in 10 000 years
genetic differences and traits between
humans will no longer be Regional
traits like skin and hair color will be
evenly distributed around the world
maybe that will help us all get along
finally
twenty thousand years into the future
none of the current languages will be
recognizable
future languages will only contain one
percent of the core vocabulary words of
their present day counterparts
fifty thousand years from now will Mark
a new glacial period for the Earth which
will start a new Ice Age
Niagara Falls will have eroded into Lake
Erie completely
and interestingly a full day on Earth
will also increase by one second at this
point in time
so much more time for activities
in 250 000 years the loihi volcano will
rise above the water to form a new
island in Hawaii
and in 500 000 years it's likely that an
asteroid with a diameter greater than
one kilometer will hit Earth
unless we can prevent it
the resulting crater will be no less
than 400 kilometers across it will start
fires all over the planet and make the
air unbreathable
so there's something to look forward to
and in case that's not enough in one
million years we'll likely have another
super volcano eruption large enough to
spew out 3 200 cubic kilometers of Ash
it would produce enough lava to fill 75
percent of the Grand Canyon
this would be similar to the Toba
eruption that almost wiped out
Humanity's seventy thousand years ago
oh and the nearby star Beetlejuice will
have exploded into a Supernova by this
time
making it visible from Earth even during
the daytime
in 2 million A.D Humanity will have
settlements throughout the solar system
this also means that if populations on
different planets have remained separate
humans may have evolved into other
species adapted to their specific world
in 10 million years a huge part of
Eastern Africa will break off forming a
new ocean basin
in 50 million years Africa will collide
with Eurasia closing off the
Mediterranean Sea and a new mountain
range will form between the two land
masses
this mountain range may include a
mountain taller than Mount Everest
out in space Mars will collide with its
Moon
resulting in it developing a ring system
like Saturn's
[Music]
in 60 million years the Canadian and
American Rockies will have eroded
entirely
[Music]
in 80 million years
all Hawaiian Islands will be below the
water
in 100 million years an asteroid similar
to the one that killed the dinosaurs 66
million years ago
will likely hit Earth
one that is 10 kilometers wide
in 250 million years all of Earth's
continents will be fused together like
Pangea except this time it will be
called Pangea Ultima
but don't get too attached to it because
in 400 to 500 million years Pangea
Ultima will separate again
[Applause]
in 500 to 600 million years a gamma-ray
burst will likely occur within 6 500
light years from Earth
if it strikes Earth it could damage the
ozone layer and trigger a mass
extinction
600 million years from now the moon will
be so far from Earth that total solar
eclipses will no longer be possible
and the sun's increasing Luminosity will
have raised temperatures on Earth so
much that it could halt plate tectonics
movement
in 800 million years carbon dioxide
levels will drop dramatically and
photosynthesis will no longer be
possible
free oxygen and ozone will disappear
from the atmosphere and complex life on
Earth will die
finally in one billion years the sun's
Luminosity will have increased by 10
percent and the average temperature on
Earth will be 47 degrees Celsius our
atmosphere will feel like a damp
greenhouse and our oceans will evaporate
leaving just pockets of water at each of
the poles
foreign
[Music]
be mentally prepared to take in a planet
Earth that looks nothing like the one
you remember
the human race will be gone
hopefully living its best life on some
other far-off planet
because of the intense heat lack of
water and lack of breathable air Earth
will be uninhabitable
so you probably shouldn't stay too long
instead you should head out to see the
rest of the solar system
maybe you'll find your fellow humans
there or some other form of intelligent
life
but that's a story for another what if
[Music]
are we alone in the universe
with more than 100 billion galaxies in
the observable universe and at least 500
billion planets in the Milky Way alone
don't you think we should have found
something by now
even if a tiny percentage of those
billions of planets hosted intelligent
life there would be tens of thousands of
extraterrestrial civilizations out there
yet we haven't seen any
where is everybody
we keep wondering what's taking them so
long to come
but what if I told you that even the
friendliest of all aliens could wipe out
our entire civilization for good
this is what if and here's what would
happen if aliens visited us tomorrow
[Music]
we tend to apply our theories to the
rest of the universe
we expect aliens to come for a visit
even though we ourselves haven't
traveled out of our own neighborhood yet
we just believe that they've had so much
more time for technological progress to
make space travel possible so here they
are with their shiny alien spaceship
roving above our heads
what would we do
as far as we know no government on this
planet has any sort of alien greeting
party planned if aliens suddenly showed
up on the horizon
just try to keep cool
say the aliens happen to be very polite
and sent us a signal before invading our
planet's personal space
well you wouldn't know it right away not
until several observatories maintained
by different organizations verified that
signal
yep that's it aliens are here now you
know
you got this shocking news from your TV
NASA officially confirms an alien ship
detected in the solar system not alone
in the University
[Music]
agencies and countries around the world
would be working together quickly trying
to assess the level of threat
they'd summon experts in linguistics
psychology combat and biology and have
them attempt to make first contact with
the aliens
groups of experts would record all
interactions to analyze simple alien
gestures and auditory reactions
those would help to decide whether
aliens came in peace or they intend to
do some serious damage
some people might believe that religious
leaders should do all the Talking
something's telling me that aliens
didn't learn our languages in school so
good luck to anyone trying to reach out
to them
while the world's most intelligent
people were busy trying to interpret the
aliens intentions to the best of their
ability
wait
s look like
some Evolution experts agree that things
like proteins and DNA are the same no
matter where in the universe you're from
if that's true alien Evolution would be
close to that of humans
they'd have binocular vision with eyes
located close to the brain
just like us they'd be based on land and
have a minimum of two legs for mobility
and three fingers so that they could
handle tools
still if some of our own life forms look
like this
try to picture something coming from
another planet
meanwhile on Earth while governments
were busy figuring out the action plan
the media would be keeping you informed
be advised to stay indoors and wait for
further instructions
it'd be hard to filter out what's
legitimate news and what isn't but try
not to fall for fake end of the world
news on Facebook and keep calm
at least make an effort to give up the
urge to pack up your belongings and head
for the Hills
at the same time the governments and
scientific experts would be sharing
information about alien interactions
from here the events could unfold in a
few different ways
first we may not get any auditory or
visual response nothing at all
this could mean anything from the alien
spacecraft doesn't have any aliens on
board two the aliens are waiting for
their alien backup to fry us up
another possibility is that aliens
responded and tried to communicate with
no weapons involved I can't speak to
their possible intentions for all we
know they may want to get rid of us and
keep the Earth to themselves
thanks to the language barrier our
interactions might not be going well
tensions would begin to rise
we'd be screwed
considering that these beings had the
technology to travel to earth
it's likely that they also have the
capability to develop some very very
Advanced weaponry
[Music]
civilians would most likely be hitting
the Panic Button as hard as possible
meanwhile governments would put their
nuclear weapons on standby
that would be our best and most
destructive weapon against them
or so we think
it may turn out that the aliens have
adverse reactions to things on earth
that we're all accustomed to
if say their skin melted upon contact
with water
then defending ourselves against them
would be simple
I'm not saying aliens would necessarily
bring Doom upon the Earth they may not
mean us any harm at all
but if some hazardous microorganisms
from outer space hitched a ride with
them and made it into our world
we humans might have no natural immunity
to those extraterrestrial microbes
and they could slowly wipe our species
off the planet
on the other hand if aliens weren't
coming here to make friends we'd be
destroyed long before we got a chance to
offer peace between intelligent beings
in any case we aren't ready for a visit
from interplanetary Travelers
we'd better get prepared for First
Contact
or maybe we should try to invade alien
worlds before they invade us
[Music]
but that's a topic for another what if
foreign
[Music]
you've been asleep for 1 000 years and
the view outside
is not how you remembered it
[Music]
trees Wildlife fresh air fresh water
oh oh right
this is what if and here's what would
happen if everyone froze for 1 000 years
Rising temperatures rising sea levels
declining air quality more extreme
weather more animal extinctions more
diseases
these are just a few of the consequences
we can expect if we continue to pollute
the Earth
and our time to act is quickly running
out
so what can we do if we want to save our
planet and fast
strangely enough the best thing to do
might be nothing
not sit back and watch the world burn
nothing
but everyone going to sleep and doing
nothing for 1 000 years while the world
repairs itself from all the damage we've
done
we can pretty much guarantee that Earth
will be better off but
can we guarantee that you'll wake up
sweet dreams
there are almost 300 cryogenically
frozen individuals in the United States
and 50 in Russia
and yet no one has ever been revived
from cryosleep
the hope is that the technology to wake
people up from cryosleep will be
available sometime in the near future
wait what the idea behind cryonics is
that humans can be preserved at super
low temperatures and later restored to
full health
support for cryonics is based on the
fact that many living things including
human embryos
can be successfully cryo preserved and
revived
existing cryopreservation techniques can
even preserve the fine structure of the
brain
however we can't unfreeze a brain and
make it work again
yet
but suppose we perfected the process and
made it possible to cryogenically
preserve our world's population of 8
billion people
[Applause]
where would we put everybody
the most practical setup would be to
have cryosleep Chambers in big
facilities around the world this would
make it easier to respond to any
technical difficulties that might arise
while also protecting people from the
inevitable decay of our infrastructure
but it's not like every human-made
structure would fall apart and disappear
because not everyone would be asleep
we'd need some volunteers appointees or
lucky winners of a draw to keep
everything running smoothly
Australian geneticist Ian Franklin and
American biologist Michael sulay
suggests that you need at least 500
people to maintain a stable population
with enough genetic variety
but with most of the world's population
in cryosleep our impact on the planet
would be rolled back
global warming would continue for
another 40 years after we go to sleep
but within a few decades our homes would
break down and within 100 years wood
structures would be gone and steel
structures would begin to rust
our cities would start to fill with
plants trees and Vines and New Rivers
would form since subway tunnels would
flood without pumps working to keep the
water out
after a few hundred years many species
of plants and animals would bounce back
to their original levels
you know before we evolved and took over
the planet
after 500 years the forests would be the
healthiest they've been in the last 10
000 years
when we'd finally wake one thousand
years into the future
we wouldn't recognize the world outside
[Music]
the planet would be Lush and green but
our homes and most of our cities would
be gone
there'd be lots of rebuilding to do once
everyone awakes but it wouldn't go back
to the way things were
the whole reason why the Earth's
population went into cryosleep was to
repair our planet
we'd likely put strict laws and policies
in place to ensure that our new way of
life doesn't waste our critical second
chance
after all we'd still have some poignant
reminders of our toxic Legacy it would
take more than one thousand years for
our carbon dioxide levels to return to
normal while radioactive material and
long-lasting organic chemicals could be
around for much longer
microplastics for example will still
exist hundreds of millions of years from
now
unless we find a way to help them
decompose
while sleeping off the effects of
climate change sounds like a relatively
easy way to undo the damage we've caused
to our planet
we probably won't have the technology to
do it anytime soon
but can we really afford to wait
the consequences of climate change are
already causing major problems around
the world
are you prepared for a lot more extreme
weather
you know how to survive a tsunami or an
earthquake
well we've got some tips for you on our
new show how to survive so be sure to
check it out
and if you're looking for a more
hypothetical take on survival like a
timeline to human extinction
well that's a story for another what if
30 000 feet
9144 meters
nine kilometers or 5.7 miles
so far only one person has survived a
free fall from that height
would you be as lucky
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell out of an airplane at
thirty thousand feet
[Music]
on January 26 1972 an explosion aboard
jat Airways Flight 367 resulted in the
impossible
22 year old flight attendant
vesnavulovic fell from 10 000 meters in
the air setting a world record for
surviving the highest fall without a
parachute
how did she survive
is there a trick to falling out of an
airplane and surviving and what does it
feel like
if you're a frequent flyer you might
want to pay close attention to what's
coming up
since the 1940s there have been almost
50 cases of people surviving Falls from
airplanes
in all of those cases the survivors were
lucky enough to have something to
cushion their fall
veznavulovich for example was in the
back of the plane when the explosion
happened when the plane broke apart the
tail section remained intact and pinned
by a food cart vulavich was prevented
from being sucked out into the open air
the detached tail of the airplane landed
in deep snow in the mountains of
Czechoslovakia
suffered several broken bones but the
airplane wreckage and layers of deep
soft snow ultimately saved her life
the second highest fall without a
parachute that someone survived happened
in 1943
Air Force Gunner Alan McGee's bomber was
hit by enemy fire over France
his plane burst into flames and
propelled McGee out of the plane before
he could grab a parachute
McGee fell about 6 700 meters
apparently he smashed through the glass
roof of a train station and was found
hanging from the steel girders that held
up the roof
you wouldn't think that a glass roof
would cushion any kind of fall but if it
hadn't have been there McGee might not
have survived
so if you ever find yourself falling
from an airplane without a parachute
grab onto something anything and use it
to break your fall
of course that's easier said than done
when you're in free fall from 9144
meters in the air a soft Landing is
probably the last thing on your mind
it all happens so fast from the moment
you're outside the plane it's only 170
seconds until you hit the ground during
that time you will be extremely cold and
deprived of oxygen
the average temperature at 9144 meters
in the sky ranges between minus 40
degrees to minus 57 degrees but you
wouldn't feel it for long because you'd
pass out soon after leaving the aircraft
while all air contains 20.9 oxygen at
higher altitudes there is lower air
pressure so it feels as if there's a lot
less oxygen
this will cause you to lose
Consciousness at least for a while
the air pressure will gradually rise as
you get closer to the ground so you
would probably wake up again after about
a minute of free fall
as you fall your speed will increase by
9.8 meters per second every second
because that's the Earth's gravity
eventually you would stop accelerating
and reach a constant speed known as
terminal velocity
this results from a buildup of air
pressure below you as you fall because
air can't get out of your way fast
enough
and at the same time the air behind you
doesn't fill in fast enough creating a
sort of vacuum
the difference in the air pressure below
you and the air pressure above you
creates drag or air resistance
when the force exerted by this air
resistance equals the force of gravity
you've reached terminal velocity and
you'll be moving at a constant speed
falling from 30 000 feet you're likely
to reach terminal velocity at 190
kilometers per hour
of course your actual terminal velocity
will depend on your size and weight the
heavier you are the faster you'll fall
but if you spread your arms and legs out
wide you can increase the amount of drag
exerted on you that might slow you down
a bit
you'd enjoy it a lot more if you had a
parachute though parachutes are
lightweight and very wide a parachute
would cut your falling speed from 45
meters per second down to about 5 meters
per second
if you don't have a parachute it would
help to know where to land
look for somewhere that's soft so if
there's a chance of breaking your fall a
lot of people who have fallen from
airplanes and lived have survived due to
Landing in deep snow or being cushioned
by trees or bushes
unfortunately a tree can either be
really good or really really bad
if you don't see anything soft below
your best bet is to try to land feet
first with your legs together slightly
bent when you hit the ground you'll
likely crumple to the side or back
this is known as the five-point impact
sequence and while it will be incredibly
painful it will save everything above
your waist mainly your vital organs and
your brain
of course these are all just
recommendations
tips to make the best out of a bad and
severely unlucky situation
humans aren't really built for
9144 meter free Falls and yet every year
we seem to achieve something that we
thought was impossible
so before your next flight you might
want to pack a four-leaf clover just in
case and for more ways to survive freak
accidents paranormal activities or
apocalyptic events
just keep watching what if
[Music]
could there be an even better planet for
us than Earth
scientists are searching for a super
habitable world that wouldn't just rival
Earth but be a place where life could
Thrive even more easily
and they're looking at exoplanets
how would we discover earth 2.0
what would make an exoplanet habitable
and how long would it take to get there
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we discovered